me permettrait d'abord de saluer même
par la voix mes collègues élus réélu
l'ensemble de mes collègues ici présents
et l'ensemble des personnels qui
assurent cette soirée d'accueil ici au
sénat aujourd'hui 171 sénateurs ont été
élus par les 76 1359 délégués
sénatoriaux de 44 circonscriptions de
métropole et d'outre-mer et représentant
les français établis hors de france
cette élection clôt une année électorale
exceptionnel qui aura bouleversé les
schémas traditionnels
après les élections législatives
tous les pouvoirs et elle est tenue par
une majorité issue de l'élection
présidentielle les grands électeurs ont
aujourd'hui conforter la majorité
sénatoriale
c'est la voix des territoires qui s'est
exprimé ils ont clairement affiché leur
volonté de voir exister un contre
pouvoir parlementaire indispensable à
mes yeux au fonctionnement équilibré de
la démocratie la majorité sénatoriale
est diverse mais elle est exigeante est
positive nous allons tous ensemble
poursuivre les réformes engagées
notamment depuis trois ans pour mieux
faire la loi
mieux contrôler le gouvernement
nous sommes dépositaires de ce qui fait
la spécificité du sénat et la force du
bicamérisme une assemblée de liberté et
au pluriel le mot liberté qui résiste
aux pulsions qui
protège sur l'indépendance et où chacun
se respecte notre assemblée devra
pleinement assumer sa double mission
être garante de l' équilibre des
territoires être garante de l' équilibre
des pouvoirs
c'est ce rôle de stabilisateur
institutionnels qu'incarne le sénat le
message envoyé me paraît clair les élus
locaux qui sont au service quotidien de
nos concitoyens ont besoin de stabilité
de prévisibilité
ils ont besoin d'une relation de
confiance et de respect avec l'exécutif
oui respect et confiance qui ont parfois
manqué ces derniers temps le 2 octobre
je présenterai à mes collègues ma
candidature à la présidence du sénat sur
un projet que je leur ai adressé au
début du mois de septembre
s'ils me font confiance nous
poursuivrons ensemble notre mission au
service de la france
je vous remercie